this is the story of three heroes whose
efforts helped ensure the world today is
dramatically better than it may have
otherwise been
the story is not an easy one to tell
involving many other players from
geophysicists and atmospheric chemists
to environmental activists politicians
and bureaucrats
but it all started here with a common
household fridge or rather what fueled
it
the earliest fridges were powered by
dangerous toxic gases but humans are
nothing if not great innovators
and so in 1928 the world welcomed
chlorofluorocarbons
cfcs proved a flawless non-toxic cooling
system and over the next 60 years they
found their way into everything but
little did we know that this super
substance was doing more than cooling
our food and fixing our hair
as cfcs moved skyward interacting with
ultraviolet radiation chlorine gas would
break free and set off a series of
chemical reactions that destroy the
atmospheric layer protecting us from
solar radiation the ozone
atmospheric chemists had been aware of
the effect cfcs could have on the
atmosphere since 1974 but had expected
depletion to happen slowly across many
decades
and the corporate incentive to not
recognize the threat of cfcs was
overwhelming
then everything changed
joe farman and his team at the british
antarctic survey measured a loss of
ozone above antarctica and this loss was
far greater than anyone had expected
they'd discovered an ozone hole larger
in size than antarctica
it was atmospheric chemist susan solomon
that would determine the whole's cause
the sunlit clouds that form only in the
coldest airs were speeding up
destructive cfc reactions
with this new data projections indicated
the global ozone would collapse by 2050
leaving the planet fully exposed to
damaging radiation that would quickly
alter the dna of all life on earth
by 2070 we'd see ecological devastation
and the collapse of agriculture
the revelation shocked the world into
action the international community came
together to ban cfcs on the 16th of
september 1987 the montreal protocol was
signed
governments were now faced with having
to phase a hundred different chemicals
out of 240 industrial sectors
stephen anderson from the u.s
environmental protection agency the
so-called can do man made it happen
working tirelessly with industry to
develop hundreds of cutting-edge
cfc-free technologies
the treaty worked production of cfcs
ground to a halt their concentration in
the atmosphere began to drop and the
ozone hole is now closing
indeed the montreal protocol has been
described as perhaps the single most
successful international agreement to
date and without the contributions of
farming solomon and anderson it may
never have happened
that's why this year we celebrate them
with the future of life award honoring
individuals who have steered the course
of history away from disaster without
having received much public recognition
at the time
the protocol is much needed proof that
the world is capable of coming together
to solve the climate crisis and more
generally tackle global catastrophic
threats
in a time of widespread pessimism about
humanity's prospects this should give us
cause for optimism